hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
I visited the Google pop-up store in
lower Manhattan and it turned out to be
pretty dope it's actually like super
photogenic so I'm putting it together
into this quick video for those of you
who can't visit and want to see it now
you can worried if you can go you can
check this out so they're not actually
selling anything here it's pretty much
just for display and demo purposes so
they're calling it a pop-up shop but I
mean it's a pretty elaborate pop-up shop
if you ask me but yeah basically they
have it set up with different targeted
areas around where each one shows a
different made by Google product now on
the wall in the front is this big wall
of Google colored swiveling blocks and
it looks pretty normal at first but kind
of swivel to display different messages
which is cool but when you walk past it
I don't I don't want to ruin the
surprise of how it's done but basically
there are sensors in the room that will
move the blocks to follow you it's
actually super entertaining I feel like
you could play with it for hours if you
wanted to it's about the most pointless
but coolest damn thing I've seen in a
while
okay over here you can see a literal
photosphere made of tablets to
demonstrate google photos and search
ability which is low key one of Google's
best products right now
then there's the Google home section the
whole Google home section is sort of
this mock-up home set up with a bunch of
normal things you might expect to see in
a home or an apartment now my full
google home review is coming up so
you'll see everything you need to know
about that product pretty soon but yeah
they basically planted different prompts
around and had an actual Google home in
there so you can walk around the room
and go through these prompts and have it
answer you and perform these actions
which is pretty helpful
they also outs I had a bunch of Google
homes and all the different colors to
look at they were all unplugged
obviously but you can see they're
supposed to give you a sense of how easy
it is to change the colors of the base
if you're into that and then they had
this low-light photo area and this was
all to highlight the pixels camera so
you can bring your own phone in there if
you want and try to take pictures but
it'll be pretty dim obviously but with
this minimal lighting you can bring the
pixel in there
and I'm sure a few other smartphones
would have been decently as well but
this was like a prime low-light photo
test for the pixel to perform well and
it looks really good it crushed it so
that was fun to play with now outside of
that was my personal favorite area the
VR section to demo the daydream view
that just came out so you can see the
whole area is themed like the daydream
view home and all the graphics and you
can see you can basically just step
right up sit down on one of these
swiveling rock stools put on daydream
view headset and grab the controller and
go to town and again the whole point is
to give people a demo so most people
still haven't really tried good VR yet
you know like they may have heard of it
but 99% of people haven't tried an
oculus or a PlayStation VR or revive and
even I still haven't tried all the ones
I want to so this was an easy way for
people to just walk in and get a demo
trial in the headset watch some videos
play some games and decide if they're
into it and I guess a lot of people were
so that was my favorite area but
probably if you ask what other people's
favorite area is it's just the pixel
demo area it's a bunch of pixels sitting
on a desk or on a table you remember how
I said this is a phone you actually have
to use to understand how good it is well
I guess here you can pick up and use a
pixel or pixel XL for yourself it's
obviously still attached to the security
tether but you can use Android 7.1 try
the assistant and all his glory this is
apparently like the most popular thing
to do here and that was pretty much it I
actually showed up a little before it
opened to torrid so that's why it looked
pretty empty no one's here but right
when they opened it people open the
doors and we're walking in and checking
it out if I'm reviewing this thing I'm
giving it like an a-minus like I was
really happy with how photogenic it is
obviously this LED lit beam in the
middle here which doubles as a huge
softbox made the lighting kind of on
point um I kind of wish you could try
the pixels with less of a security
tether but hey for a pop-up shop that's
open for a couple weeks this is sick I
say check it out if you can like if
you're on the area hopefully you enjoyed
this quick video of all of it thanks for
watching thanks for Google for having me
over and I'll talk to you guys in the
next video peace